you are
the best chess player in the world
and you not playing the world
championship really
makes the world championship not seem
important or i mean there's an argument
to be made for that
um is there anything you would like to
see if you had changed about the world
championship that would make it more fun
for you and better for the game of chess
period for everybody involved so i think
12 games or now 14 games that there is
for the world championship is a fairly
fairly low sample size
if you want to determine who the best
player is or at least the best player in
that particular match up you need more
more games and i think
to some extent
if you're going to have a world champion
and call them the best players you best
player you got to make sure that the
format
increases the chance of finding
finding the best players so i think
having more games
and if you're going to have a lot more
games than you need to
then you need to decrease the time
control a bit
which
in turn i think is also
a good thing because
in very long time controls with
deep preparation you can sort of mask a
lot of your deficiencies as
as as a chess player
with because you have
a lot of time to to think and to defend
and also
yeah you have deep preparation um
so i think those would be
for me to play uh those would be
the the main the main
the main things more
more games and less time so you want to
see more games
and uh rules that emphasize pure chess
yeah but already
less time emphasize
emphasizes pure pure chess because
defensive
techniques are are much harder to
execute with with little time what do
you think is there a sweet spot in terms
of are we talking about blitz is it how
many places a bit too fast um
to their credit this was suggested by by
feed as well
for a start to have two games per day
and let's say you have
45 minutes
a game plus
15 or 30 seconds per move that means
that each sessions will probably be
about
or a little less than two hours yeah
that would be would be a start also
what's
what we're playing in the tournament
that i'm playing here in
in in miami which is um four games a day
uh with uh 15 minutes plus 10 seconds
per move
those were would be um more interesting
than than the one
there is now and i i understand that
there are a lot of traditions people
don't want to change the world
championship that's that's all fine i
just think
that um
the world championship should do a
better job of trying to reflect who
who's the best overall chess player
so would you would you say like
if it's faster games you'd probably be
able to get a sample size of like
over 20 games 20 30 40 you think there's
a number that's good over a long period
of time well i would prefer as many as
possible it's like a hundred um yeah but
let's say you play 12 days two games a
day you know that's 24. yeah i feel like
that's already quite a bit better you
play like one black game one wide game
each day endurance wise that's okay yeah
i think that's fine like you will have
three days as well so i don't think that
will be will be a problem
um and also you have to prepare two sets
of openings for each day which makes it
more difficult for the teams preparing
yeah i think it's also good
you